monkeys definitely feed off of your
feelings they know when you're feeling
down or when you're feeling funny it's
kind of an urban legend that people out
there training monkeys to help people
with disabilities but that really
happens
i had my monkey casey for 10 years
in 2005 i was in a car accident i
enjoyed c1c2
spinal cord with a
brain injury
i
couldn't move
really anything at all i couldn't talk
you know i've come a long way
our goal is to train and place capuchin
monkeys with people living with mobility
impairments
the program got its start really as an
experiment to say we can train a dog to
help somebody who has visual impairment
perhaps we can train a primate to be the
hands for somebody who's had a spinal
cord injury
we provide our monkeys at no charge to
our recipients
all of our monkeys are born into our
program typically a monkey will spend
about three to five years at the monkey
college learning tasks whether that's
fetching a phone or remote control off
the floor
helping somebody get something to drink
even something as complicated as
flipping the pages of a book
the monkeys do really act as hands and
give them that level of independence
back
you can imagine having a spinal cord
injury and all of a sudden you have a
monkey that's sitting on your shoulder
and you can finally feel that touch to
have that monkey there is an incredible
bonding experience
when i couldn't move casey little
offered me casey brush
now
it's a lot of
emotional support
it's a lot of
companionship
casey is part of my family you know this
is a five pound animal that
is extraordinarily helpful and
brings joy to my life
you